In late February, came an announcement…
Astronomers had discovered Trappist-1!!
A potentially habitable planetary system!
The planets were Earth-sized and rocky!
There were seven!
That’s so many planets (probably)!
Now that the media has stopped losing their
collective chill, Seeker is here to bring
y’all back down.
This is the image you probably saw of Trappist-1.
Beautiful right?
Well, guess what sport, that’s an artist
rendition.
Here’s the actual image of Trappist-1.
That’s the star.
The planets are too small to be seen.
It’s still great!
Revel.
Love.
Okay..
Now.
You cannot move to Trappist-1.
You cannot live on Trappist-1.
Chances are nothing else does either.
That said, it’s still exciting!
To catch you up.
The hubbub came when NASA announced a multi-planet
system 39 light-years from Earth.
The scientific paper was published in Nature
and detailed everything…
The seven exoplanets are “Earth-sized”
(not the same as Earth-like), and they orbit
really close to their star, Trappist-1.
The star is less than a tenth the size of
The Sun, and colder.
So, several of the earth-sized planets are
in the habitable zone; meaning they orbit
the perfect distance to get surface temperatures
that could support liquid water (though that
doesn’t mean they have any).
Some scientists got carried away, calling
Trappist-1 our “sister solar system,”
and some of your twitter friends were ready
to move there.
Again, all very exciting.
Then, to add to the hype, another study of
the Trappist-1’s planets found they’re
so close together, that if they were to harbor
life (and they didn’t say they would) any
meteor impact on one could throw life onto
their neighbors.
Like blood spatter!
I should mention, they hedged their bets on
this, writing that the vacuum of space would
make it really hard for life to move from
one to the other, but if there was life on
one, there’d likely be life on more than
one.
But, now, as is their job, A group of scientists
pointed the Hubble at Trappist and were like,
woah woah, slow your yaw, NASA.
With all these planets being so close to their
cool dwarf star (the farthest is 94 percent
closer than Earth)... they are definitely
bathed in radiation.
X-Rays mostly.
Trappist could release enough x-ray energy
to strip all its planets of their atmospheres.
Yep.
Chances are these earth-sized rocks don’t
have an atmosphere to support life, or your
twitter friends.
On top of that, when planets are as close
to their star as the Trappist-1 planets are,
gravity makes them “tidally locked.”
Meaning, they don’t spin relative to their
orbit.
The light side bakes, while the dark side
is super cold.
Further decreasing the chances for life.
There is a small glimmer of hope: if perchance
the system is only 500 million years old,
then the planets might still have atmospheres;
the x-rays wouldn’t have blown them away.
The Hubble data could also show there might
be water vapor in the upper atmosphere of
the planets -- but there are no guarantees.
More research is needed.
So, again, probably no atmospheres, probably
no spinning, probably no life.
But still exciting!
This is the most number of planets around
a single star, and the most that could hold
liquid water.
Reminder: we didn’t know there were any
planets outside of our system until 1992!
And if any of the planets have volcanic activity,
or a magnetic field to protect the surface
(like we do) then the might have some type
of life on them.
We’re going to keep an eye on this and will
update you if they find anything else out
(trust me, they’ll be lookin’).
In light of all this, would you still want
to visit Trappist-1?
Tell us your thoughts in the comments.
What if Pluto was a planet again?
What if our moon was a planet?
What if we had 110 planets in our solar system?
All of this could happen -- to learn more
watch this video.
Thanks for watching everybody.
See you next time.